der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk wird
in vielen Formaten fürs Gendern die
meisten Schüler Gendern nicht das
wollten Macher einer Sendung im
Bayerischen Rundfunk ändern wollten
unter jungen Menschen Begeisterung fürs
gendersternchen wecken das ist
ordentlich nach hinten losgeht hätten
sie sich nicht erträumen können das
möchte man meinen und genau das hier ist
vor laufender Kamera dann passiert
aber die Bemühungen sind schon da gerade
in der jungen Generation und das merken
wir natürlich auch als Landesschülerrat
es kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen
drauf an wie die Lehrkraft dahinter
steht auch ob die Lehrkraft selbstgender
ich möchte unsere Zuhörenden alle
ansprechen aber auch die Menschen über
die ich berichte und wenn ich sie wenn
ich nicht binäre Menschen weglasse weil
ich zum Beispiel nicht Lehrkräfte sag
oder schüler:innen dann
verneine ich dass sie existieren die
sagen wenn man drittes Pronomen
verwendet also nicht nur sie und er im
Deutschen gibt es sehr und im
schwedischen gibt es aber eben neben
hann und Horn Henn haben wir denn
Kommentare auch aus den Schulklassen das
würde mich jetzt interessieren ich ist
noch sehr viel reingekommen also viele
die auch dem Gendern zustimmen und es
ist schon fleißig abgestimmt worden
vorne liegen gerade zwei gleich auf
Gendern finde ich weiterhin unnötig und
habe da keine Meinung
Gendern finde ich ab jetzt Klasse hat
leider gar niemand
angeht also es hat niemand überzeugt die
Runde jetzt
also ich glaube es ist tatsächlich einen
Aufruf sozusagen nächstes Jahr wieder
diese Veranstaltung zu machen ob sich
was verändert hat in einem Jahr
sondern finde ich ab jetzt klasse
findet etwas Zuspruch aber weiterhin ist
ganz vorne Gendern finde ich weiterhin
unnötig bei uns im Studio ist
bildpolitikexperte Sebastian Geisler
Sebastian schön dass du da bist das ist
kräftig nach hinten losgegangen man
merkte richtig wie die Moderatorin
plötzlich so ein Straucheln kam das war
ja anscheinend eine live-abstimmung und
plötzlich war dann nur noch dieser eine
fette Balken zu sehen denn dann finde
ich unnötig war so schief gelaufen in
dieser Sendung ja die Macher oder Macher
Ihnen wie die sich wahrscheinlich nicht
damit gerechnet dass die Schüler ihre
eigene Meinung mitbringen und nicht
überzeugt sind von dem was hier aus
meiner Sicht durchaus ideologisch
vorgebracht wurde fürs Gendern das war
aber gar nicht so vorgesehen die dachten
wahrscheinlich sie machen mal so ein
gender Talk und dann sind ja auch das
sieht man ja schon in der Gäste Auswahl
mindestens vier Gäste waren klar fürs
Gendern auf dem Podium zwei dagegen die
Moderatoren hat nicht neutral durch die
Sendung geführt sondern sie war
eigentlich auch fürs Gendern das war
anhand ihrer Kommentare wir haben es ja
gerade gesehen auch durchaus ja
ersichtlich sie hat ja sogar gesagt also
wenn die Mehrheit jetzt dagegen ist da
müssen wir einfach noch mal so eine
Sendung machen und dann sind die Leute
vielleicht eher dafür das ist ja weiß
kann man das so macht so geht es
eigentlich nicht das ist keine keine
offene Diskussionssendung sondern das
hatte er was von indoktionen im Fall
Sebastian was denkst du denn über die
Schüler da bin ich ein bisschen stolz
auf die Schüler weil die sich nämlich
nicht jetzt hier überwältigen lassen
nämlich von solchen indoktrinierenden
Argumenten teilweise sind es ja auch
Scheinargumente die fürs gender
vorgebracht wurden es ist ja so es soll
ja auch im öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk auch ein Politikunterricht
übrigens kontroverses auch kontrovers
dargestellt werden das haben die Macher
nicht gemacht die waren so gesagt
Gendern ist richtig so da gibt es ja
diesen Effekt der sozialen Erwünschtheit
die Erwachsenen wollen das so und so
haben wir also ich vielleicht auch so
oder so nö haben die Schüler nicht
gemacht die haben gesagt bin weiterhin
für das gegenst Gendern überzeugt mich
nicht mache ich nicht und weil die
Erwachsenen waren hier offensichtlich
völlig fassungslos dass das falsch über
rauskommt es ist eigentlich es ist
lustig es ist ein Stück real Satire
geworden weil die Erwachsenen ja auch
voll immer sagen naja die jungen Leute
die wollen ja gerne Gendern und das hat
genau das Gegenteil erwiesen ein breite
Mehrheit im Land gendert eben nicht die
Leute sagen nicht ja ich gehe rüber zu
meinen Nachbar innen oder ich habe eben
mit Nachbarn gestern zusammengesessen
also das ist völlig normal das ist
völlig okay das ist vollkommen legitim
es wird einem dann auch von den gender
Befürwortern gesagt ja da bist du aber
irgendwie das ist altbacken oder oder
konservativ oder rechts oder alles
mögliche das ist halt einfach Quatsch
das ist unsere ganz normale
Alltagssprache die wird von Schülern
gesprochen die wird von den Menschen im
Land gesprochen und beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfahrt wird
sie vielfach offensichtlich nicht
gesprochen und man sieht wie sehr diese
Menschen dann manchmal diese Macher in
der eigenen Blase vielleicht auch
gefangen sind im eigenen denken dass sie
das gar nicht mitkriegen und deswegen so
überrascht sind dass das abgelehnt wird
auch von Schülern viele sagen ja auch
Sprache verändert sich glaubst du dass
ich über kurz oder lang das Gendern in
Deutschland doch durchsetzen wird also
Sprache verändert sich irgendwie schon
und permanent aber es wird ja hier
offensichtlich das Gendern versucht man
ja hier so von oben durchzudrücken und
das Leben die Menschen halt ab und man
merkt ja auch es passt nicht in einem
persönlich in den in den Sprachfluss
rein immer zu sagen Ihnen ihnen innen
sondern man spricht so vor sich hin das
ist in dieser Kunstpause dieses innen
das stört ja eher da muss man sich zu
zwingen dazu eine Sprache zu dem man
sich zwingen muss die passt nicht in den
Alltag deswegen glaube eigentlich nicht
dass ich das in der breiten
Öffentlichkeit tatsächlich durchsetzen
wird klare Haltung Dankeschön Sebastian
Geißler danke
[Musik]